[Musique]
les petits parisiens de 12 à 14 ans vous
raconter les histoires qui sont arrivés
dans leur quartier de la porte d'ivry
ils ont écrit eux mêmes les textes de
ces histoires comme ils ont pas un même
des vitres des grandes fenêtres de leur
place pour que la vie soit un peu plus
belle autour d'eux
ils ne savent pas encore bien lire des
contes et car comme on dit ils sont un
peu en retard mais le monde ça ils le
connaissent déjà par coeur
c'est un monde de parisiens plein de
belles pelouses de grun de cheminées
d'usiné de fumée de voitures mais
quelquefois un oiseau champ
alors on devient gay et c'est comme un
jeudi
[Musique]
en bas de la côte j'ai vu des ouvriers
renommée de la terre lun 2010 finie la
zone de maytie même il y aura un grand
boulevard
alors j'ai songé que bientôt aussi ne
pourront plus jouer que les clochards
n'y viendront plus dormir que les
boulistes ni tirs ont plus de boules
on n'arrête pas le progrès
[Musique]
le grand boulevard est menée dans sept
le picard tout
[Musique]
à côté de chez moi on a commencé un pont
en béton cette le mail on arrache tout
les armes du boulevard masséna
du temps que cette vieille dame en noir
allaient encore à l'école
c'était la campagne ici
le copain de mon frère avait laissé son
vélo devant chez lui
[Musique]
quand il a voulu le reprendre le vélo
avait disparu
[Musique]
et ici comme partout ailleurs ce qui
vous protège si bien qu'entre les
voleurs contre les coûts des garnements
contre les fumées des usines c'est une
fée il y à une fée m'a fait ma nuit mon
soleil monte à thème mon avenir mon
collier mon village ma libellules ma
fourrure comme un poisson mon sommeil
maman de l'hymne au printemps
mounir ont des noms chez de ma lune de
miel au mois de mai
ma maman
avec les mamans on entre tout le monde
merveilleux des états unis
[Rires]
je suis allé au prisunic c'est au métro
mairie d'ivry j'ai utilisé l'escalier
mécanique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec les papes passé comme la campagne
peut pas va souvent à la pêche sur le
pont national
et l'emportent des asticots et il
rapporte des bouchons
nous faut vider pour échanger des
asticots contre des bouchons
ce qui est bien et que l'école
c'est que ça vous donne des idées
nous avons fait une découverte les
aimants un tir les pièces de 100 francs
dans le quartier des garçons utilisent
cette invention pour des pêches
miraculeuses
leur ligne c'est un aimant au bout d'une
ficelle la rivière et dans ivry
c'est le grillage d'une bouche
d'aération du métro
m
[Musique]
bouche de métro des lèvres sont en faire
les dents ce sont les escaliers et elle
en mange des gens
heureusement elle les rejette
attention grosse chenilles grosses
chenilles vertes et rouges des hommes
bleus de commandes tu souffles tout le
temps tu es fatigué c'est vrai que tu es
vieille tu as plus de 50 ans
chut c'est le sifflet du départ au
revoir mais deux parisiens
[Musique]
un jour on est monté sur la tour eiffel
on dirait que les de travers
[Musique]
à ses pieds le pont sur la scène tire
une grosse langue grise
avec lemaitre on s'est penché un peu ça
donne le vertige
il y avait un gros et un petit bateau ça
s'appelle les bateaux mouches
on a vu les étrangers dessus il est
parisien dessous
[Musique]
on voit que paris est peuplé de petits
hommes
une péniche revenait de la mer
cela ressemble à un phare
on va très loin
jamais on aurait cru que paris était si
grand
certaines maisons ont même des yeux
[Musique]
on a dit à martin regarde le soleil à
gauche
pour aller dans le soleil vient 7 heures
du matin à la montagne des baleines
l'oubli par la corde pour redescendre
choisi un peuplier dans ta poche cache
une clé dans les tombes de larmes appels
l'orage attend l'arc en ciel quand il
est la soupe dessus et l'histoire furent
ceux peupliers et des jambes et des bras
à une tête maintenant
sera-t-il un homme bientôt
pour dire il faudrait pouvoir faire la
nuit il faudrait être une ombre
il faudrait posséder des rations des
branches des feuilles à demain vagabond
[Musique]
la la la la
la la la ah
lalala lalala lalala
[Musique]
là
la la la la la
[Musique]
c'est un monde de parisiens plein de
pelleteuse de grues de cheminées des
usines de fumée de voiture
quelquefois un oiseau chante
ma petite soeur a été chercher le pain
elle a trouvé un petit moineau elle l'a
ramené chez nous
[Musique]
denis à une paire de lunettes avec des
verres fumés il ne les portent que les
jeudis et les dimanches
[Musique]
où
et
avec ses lunettes dany a vu des
quantités de choses qui ne se produisent
que le jeudi et le dimanche
un oiseau près de la boulangerie une
fleur dans les ordures le papier qui
ressemble à personne
les autres jours denis enlève ses
lunettes et va à l'école
[Musique]
où
à l'école si on lit on ne calcule pas si
on calcule on n'écrit pas si on écrit on
ne rêve pas pour rêver il faut mettre
des lunettes noires comme de nuit et
quand on lit pas ne calcule pas
l'écrivain ne rêve pas tu en manges la
cantine avec des copains
[Musique]
chaque jour à la cantine
jean louis bozon la soupe aujourd'hui
comme tous les mois nous allons nous
poser
mon poids n'a pas changé
mais jean loup amélie de 900 grammes
vous comprenez vous
il s'appelle patrick jean louis d'aidé
maurice projet prenez martin [ __ ] gilles
jean loup pierrot robert jan map thierry
denis
avec le m ils sont 16 et ça ne fait
qu'un
[Musique]